good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Josh Denny is a comedian
you may have heard of him he used to
work for the Food Network he's also
pro-life personally and willing to say
so out loud earlier this month Denny Was
preparing to host a comedy show in
Rutherford New Jersey that's a half hour
outside of New York but just minutes
after the show was announced antifa
violent radical group decided to shut it
down hundreds of antifa Affiliated
Twitter accounts started bombarding the
venue called the Williams Center they
also went after the chief of police of
Rutherford a man called John Russo and
they threatened violence now at that
point a chief of police who wanted to
defend the Constitution his solemn Duty
would have pushed back and affirmed the
sacred right of free expression of every
American that's not what Chief Russo did
instead he caved the demands of the mob
he warned the venue that the venue might
face civil liability if they let Free
Speech continue if they allowed the show
to go on then he said he would shut down
the show on quote Public Safety grounds
so ultimately the Williams Center had no
choice and canceled the show
in the end the only people who showed up
at the Williams Center that night were
several police officers and they were
there to make sure there was no comedy
taking place none at all
then to add insult to injury the next
morning the mayor of Rutherford New
Jersey Frank nunziato bragged about what
the city had done he said it was his
decision to use the power of the state
to cut down comedy quote
unbeknownst to the borough nunziato
wrote an event was planned for this
evening at the Williams Center news of
which quickly circulated through social
media online intelligence led the police
department to believe that the event had
the potential for concentrate
confrontation therefore nunziato said
quote after discussions with the owner
the event has been canceled
now notice the blame shifting here the
potential for confrontation it wasn't
the comedian who was going to confront
or threaten anyone with violence it was
the radical left-wing group antifa but
it was the comedian who was punished
this is not the first time Josh Denny
has experienced this it's happened four
times in just the past few weeks shows
canceled because of threats from the
left two shows were canceled in Chicago
another two in New York and every time
the same pattern daddy would schedule a
comedy show that a huge amount of antifa
Affiliated Twitter accounts intimidated
the venue and local officials who
collapsed under the pressure and shut it
down
Denny can no longer speak at this point
the only way he can host a show north of
the Mason-Dixon line is to deliver
cryptic instructions to his fans about
where to meet secretly
like a speakeasy otherwise if he doesn't
do this all antifa has to do to end free
speech is send some tweets and then weak
leaders capitulate immediately
Josh Denny is not the only performer
being targeted and it's not just
comedians this of course is part of a
much larger campaign to end free speech
in the United States a country whose
Civic religion was free speech just a
few years ago
this is a huge change and an ominous one
anyone who tells you you can't say what
you truly believe is a totalitarian make
no mistake it's not about sensitivity
it's about controlling you it's
totalitarian
we're going to start tonight with what's
happening to comedians because free
Society requires comedians comedy is the
way we tell the truth
the presence
of comedians in a society means that you
get to mock the people in charge very
quickly and it's not an accident we're
running out of comedians
only wrote
comedy is tolerated now and that's
another way of saying no comedy is
tolerated now Elon Musk pointed this out
a few months ago in an interview with
the satire site The Babylon bee
and then you realize it's like wait a
second is
is a comedy is a comedy getting at an
essential truth or or trying to or is
there is there a propaganda element or
is it trying to push you in a particular
direction or or getting getting to an
essential truth that is humorous and
when it stops trying to get to an
essential truth that that is that is
humorous then
you know it's just not that funny well
after that interview Twitter as if to
prove it has no sense of humor at all
banned The Babylon bee their crime they
made fun of the administration's fake
trans Admiral that guy in a dress
they're calling female
we all know what Elon Musk did next he
bought Twitter at a moment we'll speak
to the CEO of the Babylon bee about what
musk must do to restore free speech to
this country
what is clear at this point is that
after Elon Musk fired half of Twitter's
employees Twitter got better why because
they were the sensors
and Twitter isn't the only company many
of whose employees work effectively as
sensors to shut down your freedom to say
what you think outside Netflix
headquarters last year a protesters some
of the Netflix employees gathered to
demand the censorship of Dave Chappelle
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's okay to laugh but you're sparking
hate conversation
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got a weapon
so what you had at Netflix is what you
also had at Twitter and it's the same
phenomenon that's canceling comedians
all over the country a small group of
politically inflamed highly motivated
extremists who prevent the majority from
saying what it thinks another word for
that is tyranny and it's everywhere one
of the few people in Hollywood willing
to fight back against this and say what
he really thinks is Adam Carolla a long
time comedian who has stayed true and
therefore funny and he mocked the people
you saw as exactly what they are
humorless babies
I need to explain to the people at
Netflix which is an interesting another
interesting Dynamic is
your job isn't that important and it
doesn't really change hearts and minds I
think people have this thing where it's
like Dave Chappelle is going to mobilize
this group of our society which never
really seems to be mobilized like his
words his words hurt and his words are
going to cause X Y and Z no they're not
he's a comedian he gets to say what he
wants and then he gets paid and you get
paid and that's called entertainment
he's a comedian he gets to say what he
wants that's no longer the rule in a lot
of places but Adam Carolla lives by that
rule still he joins us tonight subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight